The middle class was once a symbol of the American dream,...
...but the American middle class today paints quite a different picture.
Being middle-class,...
...I feel like you're really just in between a rock and a hard place.
You know, you're in a spot where everyone's like,...
"...Hey, you're doing better than, you know, low class."
"You're doing great."
"You should be fine".
And you're underneath the people who are actually doing fine.
It was at least a secure category.
Your kids would go to a school that you felt at least okay about.
You probably own a car or two and you’d own your own home,...
...and you could pay for your kid's college educations.
So, there are certain kinds of assumptions around...
...being a middle-class person that have sort of shattered.
A survey in 2018 found that a third of middle-income adults...
...don't have $400 to cover an unexpected expense.
In polls, when people are asked about being middle-class,...
...they frequently are less likely to say so,...
...and more people now urge the pollsters to suggest that they're working class.
So, I think that many people who maybe in prior years...
...would have thought of themselves as middle-class...
...now no longer think of themselves that way.
So, when we think about economic status, we think about it as some static,...
...you know, state of the world, that you are either poor or not poor;...
...you're middle-class or you're not.
But in fact, the reality is that many middle-class families...
...will experience one or a few years in poverty.
In fact, most American families will have years where they'll be poor or near poor.
That precarity, that uncertainty,...
...that is now a feature of the middle-class experience for most US families.